[Musique]
jamais un cercle au niveau du volant qui
permet d'accélérer et là sur le côté
j'ai le frein l'adaptation est quand
même assez cher qu est-ce qu en fonction
du handicap condat en fonction des
besoins qu'on va avoir ça peut être
hyper ou onéreux
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup d'organisation qui je
veux prendre les transports en commun
par exemple il faut appeler 24 à 48
heures à l'avancé donc ça c'est pas des
plus pratiques en termes de spontanéité
de rester les courses j'ai fini par
acheter une voiture qui me laisse une
plus grande liberté une plus grande
autonomie j'ai dû repasser une
adaptation en tant que personnes en
situation de handicap c'est vraiment pas
très compliqué étant donné qu'on a déjà
le code et qu'on a déjà le permis en
fait c'est juste une adaptation au
volant avec lesquels on apprend à
conduire et ensuite on passe une espèce
de réadaptation avec lequel elle durant
lequel en fait on faire c'est à dire 10
20 minutes alors dans lequel on fait le
tour du pâté de maison on voit si on est
à l'aise avec la conduite sûre et avec
les mains
[Musique]
voilà le plus difficile maintenant c'est
de tourner ce qu'il faut réussir à
tourner tout en accélérant pour se garer
c'est toute une histoire oui
effectivement c'est assez compliqué
alors dans les centres commerciaux il ya
beaucoup de place donc ça c'est chouette
et après les places handicapées
finalement elles se font assez rares
et un écho ont foré et sert être
suffisamment loin de la voiture
pour pouvoir sortir un fauteuil
[Musique]